stop
a suspect has an intense emotional
reaction after he's taken into custody
in Florida for trespassing body and
Squad camera recordings capture the man
show a range of emotions all while
threatening First Responders
I'm trying but you got me
wrapped up
scumbags dirt bags Stanford I'm gonna
find you
I'm gonna find you it happened on July
23rd in Palm Coast Florida Flagler
County sheriff's deputies were called to
a home for reports of a man trespassing
and having a verbal argument with his
family body camera video shows officials
at the scene arrest 33 year old Devin
manrique
okay
whatever
I'm going to lean up against cars
Morehead and uh
after he's taken into custody he begins
to call First Responders thugs saying
he's going to hunt them down I will tell
you Sandra your head stand against the
car Morehead on Stanford and uh what's
your name
yeah whatever
you guys are thugs so this was going to
end with a trespass warning because your
brother didn't want to do anything
you're all thugs you're thugs you're
nothing but thugs
you think you're gangster but you ain't
got any other weapons Morehead I will
hunt you I will find you oh is that a
threat that's not a smart decision right
now
Morehead Fuentes I will remember you
manrique explains he was visiting his
uncle in house Care at the time of his
arrest but moments later he pivots the
conversation saying he's hiding drugs
scumbags that's what we're doing right
now
scumbags might not be the way you like
it to be done but this
is what I know I know
I know that you have leeway to do
whatever you want
I've been so
awful and terrible towards you so you
got any drugs guns oh yeah anything
hidden yeah I can't find yeah yeah I got
tons of drugs
are you saying that's where they are
where they are is that where they are
yeah we'll go out to jail now yeah all
right I got tons
of jail oh they're right up in there
but once manrique is inside the back of
the squad car he really shows his true
colors
more we can't even throw a beard what a
little
she can't even grow a beard can't even
grow any facial hair on his face because
he's a
no
beard no mustache no nothing I just need
to know if it's all right with the car
going over there if you need me to have
a tote somewhere tell my little brother
to take it uh
[Music]
you know what
Stanford yeah telling you
yeah go ahead
I'll kill you
I'm chill what's up so we're gonna have
to talk anymore please don't well you
just said you wanted it hey we're not
gonna tell it he's gonna move it
make sure you either call us before you
go there perhaps someone else pick it up
I appreciate you officer Fuentes thank
you one crime network is searching the
country for the best detective in the
United States we're looking for the top
investigators who helped to solve the
nation's most high profile cases from
medical examiners to forensic experts or
even private eyes if you or someone you
know believes they're one of America's
greatest detectives submit your
applications now the top three
detectives will be featured on our
social media and the winner given a five
thousand dollar prize for more
information click on the link in the
description best of luck
manrique goes from screaming at First
Responders to Whispering threats and
later speaking conversationally
[Music]
Mr Devin you got enough air back there
I think I'm doing okay
um
so what happened over here has done it
over with
um I'm upset man
this is my not my idea of a day off yeah
[Music]
I'm Gonna Get You More ahead I'm Gonna
Get You Morehead so you're from Flagler
County
[Music]
my name is Stanford Stanford excuse me
are you from Flagler County's Deputy
Stanford
[Music]
all right all right
I've never been to Ohio I've never been
to the Midwest
but I'm not a bad person I'm a good
person I didn't think that's you and
everybody
yeah like I said what happened over
there
when sheriff's deputies ask whether he's
in the right state of mind manrique says
he's feeling quote crazy
yeah I know I know yeah probably not in
the right state of mind I'm probably not
in the right state of mind yeah not in
the right state of mind today baby
not in a right state of mind I'm sorry
officer but I'm feeling a little bit
crazy
feeling a little bit crazy
no I just feel a little crazy
no I just had to get that out after that
the screaming continues
what are you doing
First Responders keep their cool as men
reek argues they purposely drove the
squad car erratically to injure him
why do you turn the cop cars so hard you
threw me against the window with the
door
so Devin I'll be able to watch the
camera footage
yeah whatever
you are being recorded
yeah yeah whatever
yeah yeah of course of course well I
haven't done anything wrong
[Music]
beat me up
go ahead go ahead go ahead
manrique's next comments are ironic as
he says he's just beginning to become
upset but later says he's known for
keeping calm what's up Fuentes
Sanford excuse me
are you all right
as you can be I'm very upset Deputy
Stanford I'm very upset
[Music]
85 water I thought I was getting a
better deal because it's so big you have
not even begun
I'm a waiter I work at a restaurant and
uh I'm uh I'm a damn good waiter too
you gotta be a good what'd you do you
got to be a cool-headed a good waiter
yeah
but after that manrique begins yelling
once again
stop
manrique now faces multiple charges
including criminal mischief and
resisting arrest right now he's being
held on sixty five hundred dollars Bond
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie